war rages again in the middle east major
fuel lines are disabled by shadowy
groups of international hackers
gas shortages ravage the east coast
inflation threatens to [ __ ] the
economy
anarchists terrorize american cities at
will police departments collapse
public trust in government plummets to
an all-time low the country faces an
unprecedented combination of crises all
at once but don't worry
everything is fine the good news is that
our government
is run by a dementia patient our
intelligence agencies are mostly focused
on promoting diversity and the military
is busy recruiting feminists to defeat
the threat posed by intolerance
and hate speech uh on second thought
everything is not fine we would appear
to be to use the technical phrase
totally screwed and there's no sign of
common sense or sanity being restored in
the near future
which brings us to this on the heels of
an ad blitz by the ca
the cia touting its recruitment of
cisgender millennial women with anxiety
disorders
and gay men whose job is to keep the
campus library stocked with
stress-relieving board games
to help agents cope with their feelings
the us army has started its own
woke ad campaign a new page on the
army's website highlights the stories of
quote five young americans who quote
made the most important decision of
their lives for reasons as diverse as
they
are now the five americans all featured
in a series of short animated videos
together titled the calling
are of course exclusively immigrants and
women obviously the army doesn't want to
offend anyone by admitting that it has
white men
in its ranks most of the videos are
basically unobjectionable if somewhat
odd
for example a a lieutenant describes how
he struggled in school
searching for his purpose in life before
deciding to pursue his lifelong goal of
becoming a pilot
he assures us quote it doesn't take a
genius to become an army pilot
now this is probably true it doesn't
take a genius to learn almost any skill
but it still doesn't fill you with
confidence to hear the military making
that kind of pitch for itself hey guys
doesn't take a genius to do this
another video tells the tale of a first
lieutenant who eventually decided to
chase her dream of joining the army
after spending five years as a singer on
a cruise ship
a scene at the end of the little cartoon
shows her staring out from the deck of a
ship at sunset
singing about her soldiering dreams
let's watch that when i
was 17 i i
had such real big dreams i
said dad i wanna be a soldier
so i can be like you
and though the years have passed now
feeling just seems to last now
it's not too hard to grasp now
hey dad i gotta
feel like you
i'm just trying to imagine you know old
school
old-school army veterans uh you know
vietnam war vet hasn't been paying much
attention recently
turns on the tv season ad for the army
that's that
it just thinks what in the hell
now i doubt that our adversaries will
tremble in their boots when they see
that our military recruitment ads
strongly resemble disney princess films
but that is all nothing compared to the
profile of corporal
emma malonelord now she tells us about
her childhood
growing up at a home with two lesbian
moms and her time spent marching for
lgbt rights
eventually in college she was inspired
by her sorority sisters to pursue
quote her own adventure which is how she
settled on a career in the army where
she says she can prove her inner
strength and
shatter stereotypes if you want to see
it which
i mean you probably don't but i'll show
it to you anyway here it is
although i had a fairly typical
childhood
took ballet played violin
i also marched for equality i like to
think i've been defending freedom from
an early age
when i was six years old one of my moms
had an accident that left her paralyzed
doctors said she might never walk again
but she tapped into my family's pride to
get
back on her feet eventually standing at
the altar to marry my other mom
with such powerful role models i
finished high school
at the top of my class and then attended
uc davis
where i joined a sorority full of other
strong women
but as graduation approached i began
feeling like i'd been handed so much in
life
a sorority girl stereotype sure
i'd spent my life around inspiring women
but what had i really achieved on my own
one of my sorority sisters was studying
abroad in italy
another was climbing mount everest i
needed my
own adventures my own challenge
after meeting with an army recruiter i
found it
a way to prove my inner strength and
maybe shatter some stereotypes
along the way
[Music]
i am let me say happy that emma
has found her inner strength but
there's a question here do we want to
promote the military as a forum of
self-discovery
for sorority girls whenever we next find
ourselves in an armed conflict with a
rival super
superpower and we certainly will
eventually probably sooner rather than
later
will the military be better equipped and
able to slaughter the enemy
now that it has made diversity its first
priority now that it has sold itself as
a place to have an adventure and
prove your inner strength
it's quite telling that out of all five
of the soldiers featured in the video
series
only one says anything about wanting to
defend our nation from its enemies
national defense does not seem to be a
major priority of the department of
defense these days
perhaps that isn't entirely fair
actually let me back up
credit where it's due um those entrusted
to defend and secure the homeland
are intent on defending and securing it
from at least one physical threat
that is the threat of white supremacy
the hill has
this report this week as well it says
quality by administration's top law
enforcement officials on wednesday
pledged to dedicate their resources to
combat domestic violent extremists amid
questions over
whether the agencies are equipped to
monitor such threats in the wake of the
january 6 capital riot
attorney general merrick garland and
homeland security secretary alejandro
mayorkas appeared before the senate
appropriations committee for
a hearing on domestic extremism as
congress ramped up its scrutiny this
week
of the circumstances around the attack
of the capital both garland and mayorkas
testified that white supremacist groups
posed the most serious domestic national
security threat in the u.s
reinforcing what analysts have long
concluded about far-right organizations
both the attorney general and the
secretary of homeland security agreed
with senator patrick leahy's statement
that white supremacists represent quote
the most persistent lethal threat
let's watch that moment could you agree
with your
predecessors that white supremacist
extremists remain the most persistent
lethal threat in the homeland
i do believe they they do at this time
mr chairman and attorney general garland
do you agree
i do and that's the most recent
assessment of the fbi
first of all when are the how old is
that guy
640 just retire
you people um
anyway going into more detail garland
went on to to claim that uh
quote the top domestic violent extremist
threat we face comes from racially or
ethnically motivated violent extremists
specifically those who advocate for the
superiority of the white race
in other words says garland the greatest
threat we face comes from
violent extremists but not the ones
who've been rampaging through our cities
inflicting billions of dollars of damage
blocking traffic harassing innocent
people
and attacking random bystanders those
extremists are often racially motivated
themselves
but they're not the ones we should be
worried about instead according to the
people at the highest levels of
government
the racially motivated extremists that
should attract our attention are the
ones who aren't doing anything
and are nowhere to be seen black
supremacists can whip up a mob of
thousands
in an instant and terrorized cities for
weeks on end
white supremacists can't do anything
close to that probably because they're
hampered by the fact
that they don't exist for the most part
which is a little bit of a logistical
challenge i have found
uh you know if you want to do something
but you don't exist it's kind of it it
presents problems
this is a threat that guys like garland
have fabricated now perhaps they
really are up at night frantically
tossing and turning screaming no
the white supremacists are coming but i
doubt it
the people who invent the boogeyman
don't actually believe in it themselves
it is more that they are politically
bound to this conclusion
but whatever the motivations we are left
with the reality that the people running
our government
and in charge of defending this country
against enemies foreign and domestic
are all either left-wing ideologues or
hollow shells and useful pawns for
left-wing ideologues
i mean all of them
at the highest levels they recognize no
duty more sacred and solemn than to
fulfill that role
they are loyal only to the ideology
they have infiltrated and effectively
incapacitated every institution
because they will not allow any
institution even the military to have
any priorities above and beyond
the propagation of left-wing doctrine
all things
and all people must be evangelists for
their religion
that is how everything and everyone's
ultimate purpose can be fulfilled in the
mind of our leftist overlords
and no doubt our enemies are watching
this happen
and laughing to themselves and licking
their chops and biding their time
all of this i guess is just a long way
of saying that you can start a free
trial of rosetta stone today
if you want to learn chinese which you
probably should
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content